vous avez peut-être vu passer sur les
réseaux sociaux des publications ou des
commentaires qui mentionne les documents
de file mesure où les files heures
documents souvent présentée comme une
fuite confidentiel de documents qui
révèlerait des dangers insoupçonnée du
vaccin mais contrairement à ce qu'on
peut lire en ligne il ya rien de bien
nouveau ou bien inquiétant dans ces
documents
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai que l'agencé américaine
des médicaments la f10 est présentement
en train de rendre publiques des
centaines de documents qu'il a utilisée
pour approuver ce vaccin là aux états
unis il ya par exemple une liste de plus
de 1200 effets secondaires liés au
vaccin qui circule pas mal en ce moment
historique étant à première vue parce
que la liste fait neuf pages par contre
quand on s'y attarde on remarque que les
données viennent de système de
pharmacovigilance de partout dans le
monde des systèmes qui servent justement
à répertorier les effets secondaires
possiblement liés au vaccin et quand je
dis que possiblement cette nuance assez
importante parce qu'on peut pas oublier
ses effets secondaires de deux manières
causal au vaccin nécessairement un des
effets secondaires qu'on voit dans ce
document là par exemple ces blessures
auraient mais il ya des gens qui se
blesse au rhin à tous les jours pour
toutes sortes de raisons et si on se
blesse trop quatre jours après avoir
reçu un vaccin ben c'est pas
nécessairement de la faute du vaccin
qu'on s'est blessé au rein il ya un
autre document qui circule pas mal qui
indique que le vaccin n'est pas
recommandé pour les femmes enceintes ou
les femmes qui allaitent le document
existe bel et bien mais ils datent de
décembre 2020 alors que le vaccin n'a
pas encore été testée sur ces
populations là depuis ce temps là le
vaccin était approuvée pour les femmes
enceintes a été approuvé pour les femmes
qui allaitent et même recommandé par les
autorités de santé publique parce que le
vaccin pourrait réduire les
complications possibles de grossesse si
on comptera quelque 19 chose certaine on
n'a pas encore fini de voir de la
désinformation liés à ces documents là
parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore tous été
rendus publics ça devrait continuer
d'ici la fin de l'été donc d'ici là
restez vigilants
[Musique]